Ian Schrager has revolutionized the
entertainment and hospitality industries
over the past four decades he first made
a name for himself in the 1970s as
co-founder of the legendary nightclub
studio 54 a celebrity hotspot for guests
like Michael Jackson and Steven Tyler
in 1984 shraeger introduced the world's
first boutique hotel and its radically
changed the hotel industry more than 30
years later his hotels still shake up
the hospitality market with his stylish
designs and attention to detail
triggers newest project is the public
hotel in New York its mantra is luxury
for all rooms start at a hundred and
fifty dollars a night Trager aims to
disrupt the industry once again and
create a new experience for travelers
Ian Schrager joins us now good morning
good morning public what does that mean
tell us well you know everything changes
culture fashion everything except hotels
haven't changed and I think the very
notion of a luxury has changed and it
shouldn't be about a price or a business
classification it should be about an
experience and anybody and everybody
that wants to participate with luckly
should have the opportunity to do it but
you say in this there's no doorman
there's no check-in desk no spa no room
service this does not sound like luxury
to me well you know luxury is a state of
being it's a feeling suite I always hear
this thing about when you put in
technology it lacks a personalization
but I think that's bunk a pause hogwash
I mean if the technology is done well if
it's executed well if it has that would
agree about it it elevates the spirit
and lifts the experience how does it
work when you go in and check in and you
do a tech with technology you are kind
of startled by it all
it's so easy and it part of the fun and
experience of staying you know in a
modern place for modern people this is
like Airbnb has had 200 million guests I
think since 2008 is this
a reaction or a sense that the industry
is changing and that's why you're gonna
have a hotel like this the industry is
changing Airbnb really a disruptive idea
and the only way to compete with the
disruptive idea is to come up with
another disruptive idea and I think the
only way the hotel industry can compete
with Airbnb is to do those things
Airbnb cannot do which is to provide
social and communal spaces and
experiences and and that's what we've
been doing for 30 years we will continue
to do it I still don't know what happens
when I walk into your hotel I walk in
and how do I know what room to go to I
still don't understand what you're
saying well you would go up into an iPad
and you can check in with your phone you
can get to your room a lot faster you
don't have to wait on line I mean you
don't have to talk to people we do have
people you know every new idea is met
with skepticism yeah you know like the
boutique hotel was 25 years ago like
studio was 40 years ago so but but this
is a new and modern idea of the today's
people I'm speaking of studio 54
there's now book out about that as well
what was it about studio 54 that made it
such a hot place time didn't you go
Charlie did you go no I never did you
never did that's okay Charlie I never
danced it it made the heart beat faster
it's difficult to put it in a box and
define it it's just when you went there
it's like it was something really
special it was transformative it is it
gave you an absolute freedom which is an
idea we all seek and that's why I think
40 years later people are still
mesmerized by it and still talk about it
do you ever take up trying to recreate
it why try and recreate it with the
hotels not what happened 40 years ago
because times are different but that
kind of magic I still try and do how
much of it was the fact that there were
bouncers and that either you had to be
somebody or know somebody to go
there was nothing but it was not nothing
to do with it you know you can't fool
the people it was a special place when
you went in there you got this
incredible rush you know you saw two
thousand people dancing
there was only one one entity all of
those things were smoke streams
distractions the place was special and
and everything since then has been
special what kind of validate the idea
got you
well you're still doing that because you
say you're only as good as your next
party and it's not as if you're planning
something special of public you know
having a Halloween party tonight let's
go to your iPhone yeah now I know we're
afraid no one's gonna come you don't
have to worry about that again sugar you
got a good tracker thank you very much